it's time for cruise news your good news
car wash for your brain car and with me
at the best co-pilot in the biz rossi
ross matthew hey everybody hi
hi your brain car
rossi you're kicking us off today oh yes
i am all right drew we're coming in a
hot topic today first we've got a
controversial take on something that i
know you're very passionate about are
you ready to discuss vice reports gen z
says gifts you know the gifts that we
send on our phones to people well
apparently they're for boomers gifts
those are the animated photos you loop
around to express everything you want
from joy to surprise well some younger
people think gifts are choogy now you
remember the word chugi's not hip not
cool you're out you're over and they're
dusty and the fact that we're explaining
what chugi means probably means we're
chugi right well i think that a lot of
these people created the word chugi to
explain people like us
yeah right like we're old we're dusty
we're not hip and cool i love a gif i
have full on conversations with people
like i have a 90 day fiance text chain
with a group of friends and we don't
even use words we just send gifts back
and forth and we we get it we understand
each other i mean today we have some
special awards out here on the desk and
the reason i i dusted off my own awards
so i was wondering what was going on
here because i see a golden globe award
with your name on a drew barrymore
[Applause]
oh my gosh they're heavy this is this is
like 35 pounds you brought all these in
and i got a lad award an mtv award i'm
i'm upset because my nickelodeon award
broke it's a little like blimp but the
reason i brought them out was because i
won a giphy award last year yes you did
and now this is one of my most proud
awards that i have and what is a giffy
award exactly um our show gift was the
number one was one of the number one
gifts do you want to um
i was so excited to be a part of the
giphy legacy and you cannot take away
our love language and people can't
decide that something's not cool anymore
no no what was the gift that you won the
giphy for do you mind what it was a copy
of it do we have the gift
the best gift award winner look it
is that a jello mold
um
i also was making this noise
but anyway please don't take away the
giffy i need them i
i make a real art form out of them
they're important to me and thank you
giphy
for having me to your party and you're
going to always be in my life yes
all right the next story i'm very
excited about great news bridgeton fans
any bridgerton fans oh hello
and i are big bridgeton fans in season
two it's on its way back thank you march
25th and i can't speak english but i can
do an english accent we've got some
sneak peeks polygon reports that this
season will focus on anthony
bridgerton's love life and a fiery
connection that he develops with a real
spark plug
named kate played by simone ashley rossi
are you chompity chomping at that
bridgerton bit oh i'm chomping to trump
trump chomping yes i cannot wait i mean
i'm i almost put a corset on today just
to get ready for it
i am so excited i the show is full of
passion it's beautiful the sex scenes i
don't know if you've seen it
but they're intense and i miss them
i i can't imagine what it i watched
bridgerton
alone but i mean clearly if you are
watching bridgerton with someone you're
gonna get it on this show you remember
when it got me on a dating app again it
did when we watched season one of
bridgeton it said you told us that it
lit a fire relit a fire within you it
did and it wasn't just like the sexiness
it was just like oh i got lost in the
romance i loved i loved it i loved that
i loved the whole show i love that
everyone was in it i love that the music
cues are modern i love the story lines i
love the actors i did i did get swept up
in bridget bridger10 it sawed me it
defrost exactly
ding well it's season two are you
excited guys i i cannot wait i am
[Music]